who's ready to go on some dates
well give it up for the host this guy he
just goes on so many dates he's a date
expert give it up for your host hans kim
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you good to be here give it up for
these late sign uppers they're gonna go
on dates tonight and let's see how good
they are at it i'm a data expert so i
shall be judging very harshly
that's a joke i'm not that good at
dating
um i got two hand jobs in the last three
months you could say that i am uh in a
bit of a dry spell and i mean that
literally no lube was used
um
my name is hans kim i'm just finishing
off a weekend opening for joe rogan uh
having a good old time with the
number one broadcaster in the world
i'm sure he doesn't have mic issues like
this
sorry i gotta it's all tangled up
um but yeah i told joe rogan too much
about my hand jobs he told me i was he
didn't want to be in a conversation with
me anymore so i'm regretting a lot of my
life choices right now uh but luckily
tonight we have a wonderful guest who
does not talk too much about hand jobs
in fact
she is a wonderful person and a great uh
question asker she's a great interviewer
uh i had her last week on this show
please go for the very funny uh giuseppe
d dominico
giuseppe d dominico i memorized that
name and uh it's very hard to say
oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] it up already how do
you say it
oh yeah totally different yeah
thank you so much we need all the uh
paper slips in there we can get
so far we got
two women and 1700 men
this is not a good ratio there's going
to be a lot of dudes bumping dicks after
this show tonight
uh so if you don't know how the show
works you were here last week and you
actually went on a date last week how
did you feel about your date i had a
great time
it was great was a pretty good day for
having a boyfriend in the room while you
go on a date
[Music]
i brought my boyfriend on stage though
so it's okay and then he went on my yeah
and then he went on a date with your
date
yeah it was all very mormon yeah of
course we only soak
that's hot
um but if you don't know how it works i
pick up a male name and a female name or
two lgbtqia plus names and we watch two
people go on dates uh it's completely
random anyone can be called if your name
is in here i suggest you put your name
in here it's a lot of fun uh we haven't
had two asexual people go on dates
together so i'm waiting for that but uh
let's get it started give it up for this
random bucket poll let's get a drum roll
going
[Music]
the first man going up
is by the name sam do we have a sam up
in here
sam is coming up he's taking a sip
he might need more time
bring your drink
bring your drink there's only two women
here you might go on a date with someone
at your table steph
steph yay and
the other person
that's at her table
okay let's see you two date
come on up you go through that door
right there please if you're a lady
please sign up
we don't need any more men signing up
if you're a man just go go home no just
kidding uh give it up for steph and sam
going on a date for a whole minute
together
[Applause]
yeah pick up the mics and go ahead and
flirt with each other all right oh this
is literally my worst nightmare so thank
you for everything
what's up dude how's it going i feel
like i've been friend-zoned already yeah
yeah all right
how's your day going steph it's good i
was snuggling with my dog earlier trying
to have a good time and you know he's
the only man i feel really comfortable
next to you know he's a good dog
what's his name jd jack daniels jack
daniels because i am a little bit of an
alcoholic
just a little that's okay right we're
all here at a bar on a sunday night
cool cool i don't have any pets but i am
looking for a cuddle buddy so
oh that's very uh forward of you
how many cuddle buddies have you had in
your past uh not a lot it's been pretty
dry lately just like you
i guess it's a dry season in texas
that's how it works right
i have no idea yeah i was just telling
steph i just moved here i don't know
anything about texas
yeah where are you from again toronto
toronto canadian
what
i feel like i should be the one saying
uh
we have that adorable accent yeah so do
we though
eh all right all right texas relax and
time
give it up for sam and steph
going on a date with each other please
please sit down
we're actually going to interview you
now
yeah your date's not over
this is only the beginning
the nightmare continues
so how long have you guys known each
other about five ten minutes oh you guys
just met yeah i invited him because he
said he was here by himself and we are
all together now and now don't you
regret your decision yes very much so
you're now stuck on stage with the
weirdo who came alone
from canada i i can explain why i'm
alone i was walking down the street i
was hungry i saw people going to a bar
and then i found out it's not a regular
bar
and he said this is a comedy show so i
came in wow that made you sound even
creepier
you saw a bunch of people going into a
bar and you're like oh look human beings
yeah that's it i can make friends with
those exactly i feel like now you're on
a date right yeah you're in a cult right
now
you're from canada yes a lot more
friendlier there you know you we uh
we're a little more bro brash
and a little more you know
uh
less healthy we don't have health care
those are your words i'm you know
i wouldn't agree or disagree but so are
you just visiting or no i just moved
here you just moved here why
uh
got a job decided to come down here um
yeah welcome you're one of the good ones
thank you so much from the north
no i'm just kidding we all love
we all love people here uh giuseppe what
do you have any excellent questions to
ask this wonderful couple that just met
do either y'all have a twitter no no i
don't have social media why me neither
oh look at that
tell us more
you know social media what happened were
you banned
no i just deleted everything just didn't
want to use it how long has it been
since you had twitter
twitter like
2014.
wow
okay
well why because you know i like to see
people's most recent tweets but i guess
i can't find anything problematic in you
for that yeah mine are from like high
school so those are all problematic
problems
say more a problematic canadian grey
goose
all night boys
we're getting drunk
steph do you have any problematic tweets
you'd like to share with us never had a
tweet never had an instagram never had a
snapchat i've got a facebook you're a
gold star zoomer
you're a gold star zoomer you've never
sullied yourself online
what does that mean
oh you've never been online so you don't
know what gold star lesbians are
a gold star lesbian is a woman who's
never had any interactions with the
penis oh so i was just making a
hilarious joke
yeah i know it's a thing okay i respect
how old are you guys you guys both look
like zoomers you guys vape you guys have
face tattoos uh 26. 26.
wow what a what a young looking man what
a spry young man
uh are you in the
younger age bracket yes
yes i would say 22.
just kidding i'm 29.
oh [ __ ] you're old as [ __ ]
i feel it too you know especially with
these youngins everywhere i'm like [ __ ]
yeah what who is travis scott everyone's
talking about travis scott i think i
know that person
uh murderer
he's a he's a dry cleaner
i believe you so uh what kind of music
do you listen to steph
nothing everything i don't know what do
you do you don't have twitter you don't
listen to music i just listen to
whatever's on the radio and i feel like
such an old person saying that
everybody knows their parents are the
ones that listen to the radio not us
like our generation so i'm an older
person you like ads
i don't mind them kids you know there's
those ones that are just really catchy
and throughout the day you just hear
their jingle in the back of your head
you smile a little bit you know that's
good you're a good capitalist
you're helping our system function
uh sam what uh what kind of music do you
listen to uh it's pretty close
uh mostly what i'm i'm driving
whatever's on the radio
you guys are old souls and young bodies
like yeah my spotify is like like half
pop in like half like rap just what's
your most recent liked song
i don't know you don't know no i don't
know i'm sorry i don't remember
two robots go on a date yeah
why would i why would i have that
memorized do you not have your phone
i bet you his was like his last one was
like a t swift song i mean
do you like it you gotta love the cheese
i love a good teaspoon have you heard
the lover album i'm just saying
wow
you're doing great you're gonna get laid
i'm sure
not by me
i'm sorry have you ever dated a younger
guy oh yeah i'm dating one right now oh
you have a boyfriend
wow and you said your jack daniels was
your favorite man to cuddle with
you must be awful at cuddly
that's too bad
you got out done you got out cuddled by
a dog
hey that's those are the best kind of
cuddles though everybody knows what i'm
talking about right you gotta have those
kettles love cuddling a dog have you
ever dated an older woman
no not dated no what do you what do you
mean nothing had like
transgressions with an older woman
no i didn't just no i didn't say it like
that you know just no you just had a one
night stand
yeah private man
[Laughter]
what will you tell us about
this guy's had so much one night stands
they call him a mountie
oh come on canadian
nice that's a good one thanks man
so uh what's your dating life what's
your dating history been like so far um
not an amazing track record um a couple
of girls
couple of girls no no long-term
relationships no long-term you just
[ __ ] and quit it or no hitting hit it
and quit it i'm not that even i know
that's wrong
i was just trying to swear to look cool
in front of you guys
uh so you uh you haven't had a lot i
mean you work in tech right
yes
i knew it
uh you moved here you have those glasses
you definitely work in tech yeah um so
yeah i mean uh are there a lot of tech
girls that are in your field that maybe
you could code with you know c plus plus
i'm not an engineer um but i'm sure i'll
find some
austin
just build an app
i'm a paralegal so sick you know
fighting the good fight
no i just like to fight
better do it listed like four red flags
in this interview
yellow guys yolo i know that term
what are you fighting currently
you know gotta fight against all the bad
guys so
civil cases we do a lot of contracts
like
let's just say these people over here
don't pay your money that you deserve
for being up here i got you thank you
got you watch out this girl's gonna get
you if you skip out on your bill she
will get you
i would uh
it'd be it'd be tricky to date you or
marry you because then you'd be like i
can get out of this
you know be careful if i were you she's
probably got a you know she's got a good
legal mind she'll [ __ ] you
legally
there's probably a whole binder on you
already
he's into it finndom financial
domination
he actually makes more money than me
nice what is uh what does your boyfriend
do this is a good topic on a date
he's basically an oil and gas oil and
gas
so you're fighting the good fight he's
uh oiling and gassing up the environment
you gotta have both sides of the
spectrum that's just how it works right
as a couple you're a net zero
you guys are damaging and healing the
earth at the same time
and uh what do you do in your tech
industry are you
uh finance and
stuff like that i guess finance
it's good nfts right
yeah
okay you got it
thank you and for the next five minutes
sam will explain explain nfts to steph
and we'll all try not to
die
i thought i was gonna learn where the
nft was today
so what was your last dream
tell me about your last dream my last
dream you remember all of them after i
don't remember any i don't know what's
the last one you can remember
i don't i don't know i don't i don't
know what was the last tv show you binge
watched i've been watching you girl on
repeat for a while
amazing who's your favorite character
nick hands down
interesting
who's the one you're most attracted to
schmidt
love that same
you new girl new girl love new girl
i got him on it so you know it's just
one of those things that you watch and
you're just like my soul feels good that
is one of the shows that you like bring
a man to watch and he's like no i don't
want to watch it and then he loves it
yeah he loves it loves a good little
rom-com who's your favorite character i
mean i gotta love cece she's pretty
legit
i love her pizza
i've never watched new girl
[Laughter]
you're missing out
seems awesome you know good vibes
everyone's chill everyone's an adult
and i've lived with you know five guys
before so it just feels the same
the ratio here tonight five guys one
girl
it's a dynamic we're all familiar with
so uh yeah i mean uh what do you guys uh
if you guys had to go on a date where
would you guys go on a date
judging by your vibes a library
hawaii
hawaii
hawaii you gotta aim for the stars y'all
because
after that it all goes downhill for a
first date
yeah i won't be i won't be at that first
date no you've never been you've never
been a girl you wouldn't understand i
have never been a girl but uh you don't
know that it's 20 22. i could have been
a girl that's fair my bad
so let's do a little improv exercise
let's say that uh sam is a financial
guru on an app and he kind of [ __ ]
over his employees shorted them on their
wages and you are a fearless paralegal
here to battle sam
for uh his uh transgressions
uh
you guys are at an office and let's just
say uh steph walks in with a with a
briefcase and a large attitude
and action
so tell me why did you do what you did
well look it's a tough economy you know
for us to stay profitable
we have to make cuts and that involves a
lot of your friends
co-workers they have to go otherwise
we're going down so you're cutting
people's wages for the economy
if i don't do it now we'll go bankrupt
we'll lose it we'll lose the business we
lose our jobs in a year anyway so might
as well do it now
so doing it now means that you'll
definitely do it later right it's going
to happen either way oh it's going to
happen either way so you might as well
just accept it now uh so do you like
[ __ ] people in the ass or is that
just
the benefit of that i only do that in my
free time oh
you know
gotta say a lot of people love that but
i don't like it when you're doing it to
all my friends
um you know what
i got
and seen wow sam
that you're actually yeah give it up for
them
that was scarily realistic
you're actually too good at that sam
that was pretty scary
you're uh very good at moralizing your
horrible actions that was just
misogynistic enough
i like how you mentioned [ __ ] in the
ass that's always good to bring in an
office environment
just make him realize the consequences
of his actions
but usually he loves it so yeah he loves
it
but you don't actually do that right
you're just like whatever you're just
what do you do are you uh
you're not an engineer you
in your job what do you do in the in
your job
what do i do in my job please make me
feel better about what i just saw right
now
uh
it's boring but do like finance
operations business risk
like digital transformation stuff
so vague
don't know what those words yeah i just
heard math is it just math no there's no
numbers
that makes no sense to me yeah it's like
it's power points and
like i don't i don't know i started the
job two months ago i don't really know
either well welcome to austin you'll fit
right in that's most of these jobs
thank you guys sam and steph give it up
for sam and steph for going on a date in
front of us
i'm sure they'll sit next to each other
and it won't be awkward at all
now that they went on a date with each
other
what did you think about that couple if
they if they had if uh steph didn't have
a boyfriend what would you think about
them
i would say they would not work
why
maybe that are like enemies to lovers
you know yeah they had a very uh
contentious vibe yeah yeah tension for
sure yeah
sam is a bit of a douche no i'm just
kidding
steph looks like the older sister from
lilo and stitch it'd be a a perfect
match
i know she's gorgeous
this next comedian or this next date is
also a comedian give it up for ray
chenevey
maybe he'll get off his laptop and he's
going on a date with carly with a k
a carly with a k looks like she was
signed up against her will
but here she comes she's putting her
beanie on
yeah sure
it is a date you don't want to date
sober
carly's coming up this light is pretty
overwhelming over here
right
so what do you do member of the blue man
group
ray's firing away already
i can't see streaming bits give it up
for ray genevieve and carly going on a
date
hi
[Applause]
great
hi nice to meet you carly moray hi ray
nice to meet you
uh what do you do for a living
um i just moved off my boyfriend
it's pretty simple you just mooch
excellent
uh
it's called mooching how long have you
been doing that
since i was a kid
started with daddy oh okay
so
there's a two big pieces of information
that just became present oh i'm feeling
so good now
uh
you're gorgeous by the way oh thank you
i thought she was talking about me i was
this is all now worse
well thank you
this is my name again i'm rey
uh
what do you do
uh i'm a av technician for a hotel av
that means atrial ventricular
yes
that's exactly it nailed it
ask you all the questions i'll be really
nice
i don't doubt that
you guys want to go on a date yes it
seems like you two are zooming yeah or
connecting ray do you want to interview
us yeah sure okay let's switch it up
nice
what's up ray
hey how you doing
let's uh try not to say anything
problematic as we watch a lesbian date
okay well we're sitting next to each
other okay are you gonna time us yeah
you're covering it perfectly it's great
and go
okay sweetie
where do you get your fake lashes oh my
gosh they're called lava i got them for
christmas l-a-v-a-a
lava how did you meet your boyfriend
that you much off of actually he hired
me for his company rent a horn
what did you do at this company is that
legal is not like an hr violation surely
i didn't say that it's hipaa
it's hipaa no that's not hipaa
hip is an honor code
probably
i could say anything up here
i see why you like it
so
why'd you wear your beanie on stage it
makes me feel confident i cut off on my
hair so oh it looks good with your face
shape thank you why'd you cut off all
your hair did you have a breakdown
me too
covet sucks cova did suck how long ago
was it
not covered your haircut yeah about six
months ago six months ago chopped it all
off like shaved your head yep have you
done that before nope got a pompadour it
sucked don't ever do it i'll pop 100
like one of those like yes oh i hate
that
my mother did too you guys i'm like half
mexican and my mom wanted to slap the
shaved head right out of me i'm also
half mexican oh i can tell is it because
i'm brown
[Laughter]
i'm not what's your other half um irish
best of both worlds aggression and
alcoholic
red flag red flag
when was the last time you went to
therapy oh my god not enough
not enough i don't know in college in
college how old are you now
how old do i have that you can lie how
do you think i am 25. ah
now i'm 30. you're 30 good for you
22. ah
oh my god and time
give it up for these wow let's go two
date
goers
so you uh
[Music]
you
do you work in the medical field
carly yes because he said av tech and
you didn't go with audio visual you went
with atrial ventricular you remembered
yeah
so what do you do
i just do this
he's really cool i just watched people
go on dates all day
wait they were talking without the mic
for a second i think they were trying to
have sex or something in the back is
that true i was trying to tongue kiss
her that is true wow way to go your
boyfriend here you gotta call him out
that's your boyfriend
what's on his head i'm sure that was
totally legal the way you guys met
so he hired you and then started dating
you did he hire you to date you or was
that just a coincidence have you ever
asked him that i actually have not
well well now is the moment of truth wow
tell us about your unethical practices
i think that's hipaa or h.r
isn't nepotism family yeah are you
related
[Laughter]
anyways
so you you met your boyfriend and now
you move you mooch off your boyfriend
and uh you don't work for him anymore uh
i still work for him yeah nice so what
do you guys do some medical stuff uh i'm
in i'm in nursing school
oh i'll be done in december of 2022.
but what do you do for him now i valet
cars oh okay park those nice cars nice
okay so you're in the medical industry
but he's not
if my doctor came in with a weed hat
with george washington on it i'd be very
afraid 420 farm road
420 bro
i like the all green ensemble too
is he irish or is does he just love weed
actually oh my god please don't get this
wrong he is
danish
danish
wow he looks like he loves pastries so
that makes sense
you liked that one
she liked that one
where did you meet here i already know
where you met your boyfriend what was
your first date how did he ask you out
like hey uh if you want your paycheck
do you want to spend it on our date
um let's see i mean it just kind of i
just kind of forced myself upon him
another hr violation
literally this man only owns track suits
one hundred percent track suit uh when
we started dating he was like
she's just jumping in my tracksuit all
the time and that's exactly where i want
to be in your tracksuit
every day
wow that's actually a mating call in
croatia
[Laughter]
eastern europe jump in your track suit
ray what do you think about uh this
european couple
uh i think it's beautiful and uh i
approve of uh all of it
proof of all of it and i i i approve of
all oh you approve of all of it how did
it feel to go on a date and then she
says i mooch off my boyfriend for a
living it was wonderful and i'm glad
that dominique took the role of the
what's my name they're not dominique my
bad
what's my name
yes
i was thinking about your last name
no that's good i like being called by my
last name it's power dominican
yeah she was uh she you were on a date
and then she got complimented for being
gorgeous yeah that was the best part
my favorite is when she took the lead
role i'm just kind of
yeah
uh
hey you know what uh get out of here
it wasn't uh
yeah that's offensive at all you know
it's okay ray doesn't have any feelings
i'm sorry ray you're a man of steel it
doesn't hurt your feelings
i'm glad that i won my jean jacket for
the first time for all of us by the way
glad that this was the first time i get
to try out this new thing of confidence
that i was going to try and mobilize
this is what jay leno would look like if
he turned into frankenstein
thank you why is only your bottom button
buttoned because i want to pop out this
yellow is that peach
i stole all this clothes from my father
just unbutton it
really
yes okay
you look like you're from the 40s
you look like a mechanic from the 30s
you look like you'd kick me off the
stage
okay so i have a question for all three
of you guys what made you i guess you
can answer this as a team unison
whatever but what made you guys want to
do comedy because you guys are asking us
what we do what about comedy i don't do
comedy what do you do
i would rather she dates a comedian i do
date a comedian do you really i know
somebody adjacent oh cliche
a comedian's girlfriend funnier dating
right there no not hans he asked me to
play katan one time though
that's how i flirt
you want to play settlers
[Laughter]
it's a good game
ray played ray you played settlers i did
it first time i didn't uh you know make
any moves to you no it was purely
platonic and a learning experience uh he
beat my ass it was five in the morning
it's all on stream that sounds horrible
it does sound like i sexually assaulted
you
i'm really glad i didn't play guitar
yeah
it was all guys too so
sick
definitely very uh
horned up well i'm sure only men can
understand that game so it's fine yeah
absolutely it's a very manly game so
carly have you ever been on a date with
another female before or is this the
first time this is actually my first
like actual official time nice
have you
we all are lucky well i don't know
what's going on here but i like it
[Music]
this is just the hodgepodge mess this up
millennials date now
[Music]
yeah do you skateboard or do you have
you just seem like a very skateboarder
type energy
used to when i was younger nice
and is that the kind of guys that uh you
were interested in are skater skater
boys
i like more who bears i like
poopers yeah you mean black men sure you
can just say black
you're going from a danish man to a
black man apparently but
a really harsh way to let him know that
[ __ ] up
so giuseppa how uh how long have you
been dating gabe for
i don't even know if he's here he's
probably doing a mic or something but um
i've been dating him for two months nice
how's it going he's a very nice guy he
is a nice guy very calm
very chill very autistic great stand-up
great he's a really funny guy i do think
he's pretty funny he writes bits a lot
though
yeah yeah they're not bad though does he
ever try out bits when you guys are in
bed
like why do they call it a clitoris
[Laughter]
nah he won't he won't you know that's a
sacred space but then like immediately
after probably yeah
nice he's always writing right you could
uh learn a thing or two do you ever
write bits in bed
uh no i write bits about my experiences
in bed though you know you want to try
one out right now
uh
no it would be interesting
he hasn't had sex recently yes yeah give
us a little sex talkie talking i don't
have my phone and i'd have to remember
what the [ __ ] i'm about to talk about so
now a little sexy i also have to look it
up
be like where my
failure at sex section of my joke book
is i'll have to find oh it sounds like
you sound like we got a good category
though yeah it's actually it's a it's a
full big it's an entire joke book on its
own you know so ray when's the last date
you've been on
uh and how did it go
on uh tuesday last tuesday last two sam
marcos was it a first date yeah
yeah it was great uh
she was she saw me perform at the san
marcos open mic at wake the dead coffee
and uh i killed with a joke about betty
white being dead
and she loved it
and then uh that was it we didn't kiss
or anything but i think we're seeing
each other next tuesday so
every tuesday every tuesday because
that she's in san marcos which is 30
miles away so i don't know if that's
gonna last but don't tell her
i'm trying to have sex with her okay and
marco has sex with her so don't tell her
that sick
yeah you might as well date a check from
uh round rock if you're gonna go all the
way to san marcos
again
round rock be honest honestly
no
atx all day baby
yeah this is the only safe spot for like
if you don't get [ __ ] on by a bat then i
don't want to date you
ray only [ __ ] 512 area codes yes yeah
or uh
yeah and definitely not people that
resemble uh other like southern
very i like the i like
austin because it kind of gives you the
vibe that's like not a southern place
like a southern city what do you mean by
southern do you mean white people
yes
no
it's just like the you know like
i don't know not like two texts it's
like kind of a
more modern people i don't know he's
saying texans are not modern
he's saying texans are primitive
backwards people
from new york so it's just i don't wanna
i don't you know i it's uh i don't know
well good luck getting an abortion here
buddy exactly you ain't in new york
anymore
i know you're really from new york
because you mentioned it yeah and the
first time you mention it every five
seconds or else you know you've got real
uh catch me if you can vibes from uh
leonardo dicaprio shady
yeah
yeah
i'm on drugs anyways give it up for
carly and ray
ask ray to see his vax card he loves it
he's from new york
giuseppe d dominico went on a date and
you're a guest you're doing all the
roles today in more ways than one
renaissance woman
nice 22
you're a zoomer
you have no boundaries
yep red flag cody's the only one in the
lgbtqia bucket i hope you're the a
i'm gonna put you in the man bucket
oh okay i'll take you out
all right we're gonna get another man up
here
hopefully or someone that identifies as
a man which is a man uh anthony w
there he goes
he's got the glasses he's got the walk
going on a date with elise
he has
chance i love to see it
elise amadon here she comes from the
back
wow
you two are gonna go on a little date oh
look he's moving for her oh
he pulled out the seat
he's already killing it
doing way better than raided
and go ahead how are you doing
um
i was trying dry january
uh
but i'm only nine days in
and i had one cocktail and i'm half
asian
yeah so i need a deep breath give me
chuffy dimer vibes
oh i'm sorry no i'm kidding no i would i
would eat you fresh i wouldn't put you
in the freezer no okay yeah that's
really nice
you wouldn't preserve me you just take
me right then and there i like that
honestly
i've been
i've been waiting to suck the bone
marrow out of a blonde woman dude i
heard it's the best protein
that took 30 seconds
are you already coming in your pants now
no i'm too drunk i probably won't come
sorry cool isn't that like the [ __ ]
austin's headline i'm too drunk i can't
come now
this is my first time in austin
and this is going a little fast
are you hungry you can't can you handle
it are we is this too much you know we
can move that away yeah this is getting
spicy where are you from i'm from
detroit
oh you have nothing to live for i do
and i'm from excuse me at least we have
a reason to be [ __ ] up
what's your guys's i'm from vegas
so why are you here it should happen and
stay in vegas remember
uh but it can't escape it does
like the virus
and time give it up for elise and
anthony w thank you
wow
i don't know i'm really trying to share
with you on the yeah no thank you for
blocking that light in my eyes two
psychos going on a day you guys can't
stop you guys are still doing it well
you guys have really good chemistry
so uh
i think she's italian well you can
handle his crazy ass things that he says
what the [ __ ] dude i mean i can't slice
it right back to him yeah that was
amazing
this is how you deal with incels
take a take a note
these are blue light blockers okay i
just they raised my iq by 20 points okay
i won't insult you i like the glasses
more can you put them back those look
like shooter glasses
they might shoot
very very beautiful man
she said
how are you doing and you said it's dry
january
and you started listing off like numbers
and like drugs and then you said i'm
half asian
that was intense that was a lot to deal
with
and then you said you wanted to suck the
boner out of a blonde woman
bone
marrow oh
nice
you know like i'm i'm always afraid to
go there on dates maybe the the ki the
trick is to like commit and just like go
whole hog with the whole serial killer
thing yeah
it works
did it work
no it didn't it didn't work i'm sorry
uh maybe keep trying it you know keep
suggesting you're amazing
um you said that uh there's a lot of
protein in your marrow so that was a
good save yeah that was good i think so
um so you're from uh you're some you're
from vegas
yes how do you like austin so far
this place is really cool
yeah everyone's a lot funnier
okay yeah people aren't very funny in
las vegas yeah this happens when you
lose your life savings
and how do you like uh how do you like
detroit how long were you there for
detroit yeah
i mean i've been in michigan my whole
life
but i mean i've been like i've been to
austin like a few times i like it are
you living here are you just visiting
nope i'm just visiting oh okay so you're
going to go back to
go back to the tundra good luck yeah
we'll send you a warm thoughts from down
here why'd you decide to come on down
well um i was supposed to go to that
duncan to russell show and he cancelled
so
left me high and dry and
figured mine as well
have fun comedy come here tonight you're
doing great you're great on stage thank
you did you cut your own leggings you
know i was going to cut my wrists but i
ended up going with the legs
i'm sorry you beat you beat anthony to
it
i love you guys you guys are awesome
thank you elise i love you elise we love
you too
uh so you're a big dunkin trestle fan
nah i mean sometimes okay well you flew
all the way out here to see him no i'm
honestly i am looking to live out here
of course who would want to stay in
detroit
so i'm you know checking
checking in a couple places nice so what
uh
where in michigan did you live in
i'm really like outside of like the
suburbs in detroit oh okay and i mean
it's
it's only cool in the summer i promise
every other time get the [ __ ] out yeah
we
know have to warn us we've seen the
documentaries
i know exactly we've seen eight mile
well no god
rabbit or rabbit you know
so is uh eminem pretty big there does
everyone like she just opened up mom's
spaghettis in like downtown and then
really i'm sure it's just like some chef
boy rd out of a can and they're just
dumping it on a hot plate
you're going to be on the next dick's
trap
is it a soup kitchen
the soup kitchen i wish
so uh
anthony
what do you do in austin
uh
i'm drinking currently you're a drinker
what am i doing here hopefully i'm going
to uh
eat some barbecue and tacos and beer
there's a lot of great food here i came
here to eat stuff my face maybe get them
killed okay
that sounded creepy dude oh you got
jokes
we'll see
this guy's so intense
no i'm nervous as [ __ ] as you can
imagine are you half japanese
no i am not that smart i'm half
vietnamese oh okay
so you got some of that for the mexicans
of asia
building a tunnel
the vietnamese people are the mexicans
of
asia i'm the mexicans of america
it's just about beer and small fried
things
look at this kill tony fan he's uh very
dark and uh
very male who knew
um
so uh do you have a you want to try out
a little a couple of your jokes right
here right now for elise okay please
yes um you have to be you can't be
nervous when you want to make racist
jokes
yeah don't be because they can smell
fear of course
like the pit bulls they fight
i think he called minorities animals
but that was a joke like like a bear can
smell fear
so do you celebrate chinese new year in
korea oh here we go
we celebrate the lunar new year
which happens to be the chinese new year
um
i am not the first person that's allowed
in the house every chinese new year
because there's
for chinese new year every year
everybody leaves the house okay and only
the most successful person in the family
is allowed back in why i'm not allowed
to come in or out of that house for two
days i've never heard oh my god i treat
my dog better than that
yeah you should see the way he treats
his dog thank you [ __ ]
if they don't listen they'll eat it
right
only the ugly ones
i've never heard of this tradition
yeah at least you have a very great
sense of humor maybe you should sign up
when to unkill tony yeah i'll be there
of course okay i'm already in i already
got the ticket oh
really you gotta take oh nice yeah i
went there for my birthday i was having
the greatest time of my life so you're a
kill tony fan look love kill tony nice i
mean we don't have to go since we're
already on here
yeah
um
probably just go to kill tony definitely
go to kill time i don't want to get
fired
i love him i'm sorry i love him
we all love him
yeah i mean
this is uh this show is pretty much like
a pale imitation of that show so it's
just a warm up a yellow imitation
sick
you're only half asian dude
if you can't make those jokes i mean
white passing would only have been cool
100 years ago
you have real uh
just escape from prison vibes
seriously
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean should i leave like should we
leave you guys as you know
have you ever either been sent
hell yeah
only nine show up i was only charged
with one though i'm impressed yeah
[Music]
just because you throw a plate and a
couple knives at a dude no i shot him
like the old texas you shot him
what part of that oh yeah on the upper
here
wow
his name was kennedy
uh you shot a kennedy you know i swear
to god shot at kennedy
that's probably the cia you work for the
cia no they work for me
they work for you they work for me no
i'm [ __ ] around no you're not okay i
have no idea what to believe
you're from detroit and uh yeah i can
totally believe you committed a couple
felonies a couple
do you like it when women scare you
i can't keep it contained
what did you shoot him with
i come with ppos what what did you shoot
him with a nine millimeter ruger and it
was like purple and like pink and it was
like the prettiest gun ever i was so mad
they took it from me
how many days before you used it did you
buy it okay so i bought it during the
like hillary clinton and trump
administration beef they were never in
an administration together before like
[ __ ] hit the fan okay it was my 2015
2016. i'm just saying it was my 25th
birthday
and i wanted to buy a pew pew
this is why you have to be crazy on the
first date
and you bought like a gun made by barbie
it was ruger barbie yes nice i thought
that i thought that anthony was a crazy
one little did i know elise was the one
with two felonies and a barbie gun and
no
[Laughter]
anthony's like
silent crazy
which is scary that's the scary kind of
yeah
you said you're going to eat her bone
marrow
that's a consequence i wanted to
okay
that's a compliment in vietnamese
culture
that's how they survived the long uh
monsoon seasons despite
suckling the hottest one eat the hottest
ones bone marrow
okay for
uh for an immigrant to get a white woman
is a big deal i don't know so so for my
dad to get a half white woman was a big
deal so you know for me why you only
have order one trophy
she was half white so you're a
quarterback
my mom my mom is i guess i don't know
what do you classify a jew as
a jew are they white
that would make me jewish a quarter
white i don't know what to do with the
jewish thing though you're asian you're
supposed to be better at math than this
[Applause]
no the the white part handicaps me a lot
i say more that's the adhd more about
how hard it is to be white
[ __ ] white is
so you said you're not white what are
you i am white i'm as white as wonder
bride you guys you know what kind of
white you are yeah the the wrong kind
the british the [ __ ] german irish
you know that the whole the good ones
right the problematic one the most
violent ones
to the most saddest that's why you shot
him with a ruger because you're german
was he jewish
are you a cat jewish i am not
anti-semitism all right he was a white
man i shot a white man why thank you for
shooting a white man
she's an ally that makes two of us
so let's do an improv exercise so i
could you know be working let's say that
uh
uh anthony is joe manz and he came
and he came he comes back at 2 8 2 30
a.m
wreaking of alcohol and perfume stripper
perfume okay and you got your you've
been waiting with your little pink and
purple ruger just like i'm shining doing
all night yeah all right and uh he walks
in and uh he uh
he demands chicken dinner or whatever
all right just go off on him shoot him
all right where have you been in action
where have you been
i just got here
i i mean but
i see that i see you just got here from
where from where did you come from
all right i can smell the perfume on you
already
i'm down there too
what is your dick stink
you gotta spray her perfume
when are you gonna pay your own phone
bill
don't worry about who pays the phone
bill because it's obviously right not
you the [ __ ] was shut off last week
i'm [ __ ] sick of this
can you
where's my chicken dinner yeah can you
like pay me to shut the [ __ ] off can you
pay the water bill
no this will pay for my hotel this is
where you shoot it keep the money
i'm kidding
all right shoot someone from the back
you gotta learn gun safety y'all you
know that yeah
you shoot a man
okay that's everything i have
i get it i get up
what do you do for a living
i'm a coach anthony you're a cook yeah
i'm a cook and a music producer
um do some audio stuff like whatever
people need me to [ __ ] do you are
white
yeah
i mean
are you gonna link your soundcloud
[Laughter]
no i'm a musician i'm a songwriter and
uh i cook i have two full-time jobs i
cook in the morning and i cook at night
do you wanna serenade at least right now
you wanna serenade her with some uh
motown classics please i don't want my
vagina any drier
it's dry january
it is dry january
can you dry up her [ __ ] with uh
no i need a guitar i can't do it
acapella
jeez
can you do it with a piano
do we have a piano player i don't know
the baby grand
um
these
eyes are crying
these eyes i've seen a lot of love but
they're never gonna see another love
like they have with you
give it up for anthony w and elise
[Applause]
going on a classic
vegas slash detroit date
keep an eye out on both of them i don't
know who's gonna murder who but
someone's gonna die tonight
that was my favorite couple that was
crazy that was good energy
uh let's pull up another date uh we got
anna coming up
and uh
from the table over there
she's coming up and the lucky man of the
night is gonna be
zach m
this guy has a girlfriend
try to steal your friend's man
let's see how dedicated he really is
all right
zach m going on a date with his
girlfriend's friend anna i've known this
[ __ ] for like 10 years i can't date
him nice
spicy
all right and
action so have you ever been in a
throuple
yes
clearly
right now with you and your girl i like
where this is going
i don't know what to ask you i know
everything about you i'm like literally
on the phone with you 24 7.
just lay it all out
i mean i don't know what do you want me
to talk about new york
you want me to talk about hawaii do you
want me to talk about
no no no it's not with me though it's
like [ __ ] that he does on his own we are
going to hawaii we are going to boy
just kidding like with a bunch of people
yeah i know him too well i can't ask him
[ __ ]
you can i'm an open book
um
what's his favorite song
i know his favorite song
what is your favorite song
22 by t swift
oh that's right i was gonna say russ but
you're right uri really he loves taylor
swift um
we went to nashville a few days ago and
all he asked the singers to sing was
taylor swift was just really awkward
she's gorgeous
and she can sing which is kind of weird
because none of the girls he ever dates
look like sailors
and time
give it up for anna and zach m
they went on a date together
in front of your girlfriend
to be fair i got friend-zoned this
morning
by your girlfriend to her mom
to her mom oh
i didn't know that one
damn i don't know what's going on she's
like my friend zach
have you all been dating again
they made on my birthday i i introduced
them
tell me more so
uh
please don't please do you already
started i i have to so on my birthday i
went he lives in houston and i went to
houston because austin fc was playing uh
the dynamo
and i really wanted to go watch them so
we all went for my birthday and she's my
friend so i invited her to go he was in
houston and i kept talking about her how
she was so great
and they ended up meeting at the game
and now they're inseparable and now he
comes to austin like every week and i
just kind of third wheel all the time
which is great
that was the most millennial way oh wait
no yeah he got into a fight at the game
actually
on the day that you guys met yeah yeah
yeah so there was like a huge fight with
like the two uh like the los verdes and
the whoever the dynamo have as a fan
group and they uh they started getting
into a fight this [ __ ] goes and
goes get gets water or drinks i don't
know what you're getting alcohol
and he goes gets water and he goes
literally in the part where everyone's
fighting and i'm just like why like you
literally could have gone around where
there was no one there um so he gets hit
in the face
i thought my cousin had gotten hit in
the face but it was him so then she goes
and tells him that
if he doesn't stop trying to fight
everyone else she's not going to give
him his number or her number and that's
how they started dating so he stopped
fighting and then she was like okay i'll
give you my number yeah she wiped blood
off my face on our first date
[Laughter]
was it your blood or someone else's
blood yeah i technically got cheap
shotted and then my glasses he was being
a little [ __ ] my glasses fell off i can
see like this far so i swung back into a
fight at a soccer game and your glasses
fell off i hit somebody i don't know if
it was the person that hit me
because i can see like this far without
my glass i can see why you started
dating him
this guy just lashes out violently
i don't have more of this in my life
passionate reckless king
so uh you're from houston and you went
to see a soccer game uh no i'm from
austin but i live in houston now for
work okay
do they make fun of you for being a
soccer fan in houston does that look
down upon
i don't think so he's not a soccer fan
he went for me yeah like he how did
y'all meet we met in college
um
yeah we went to ut and uh we met at a
hispanic group that we were both in
i think i was in that group hsa yep
really no way
look at us
i was gonna say chipotle
no i was actually president he was the
president i don't know how but you mean
presidente
i'm sorry
no disrespect yes thank you for
correcting me
that's awesome so you guys are both
hispanic and uh why didn't you ever date
him
because
i know too much about him what is the
one number one thing that makes you not
want to date him besides his violent
tendencies
i don't want to say in front of his
girlfriend
oh [ __ ]
now we definitely have sooner or later
she knows i mean
he's kind of a hoe he's in a demon arc
right now so i i have a job
i retired from the game he says yeah
no one no one wants to be on a do you
have a snapchat still no
i am i'm also off of social media that's
also a lie no oh wow he says that and
then he watches my stories on instagram
and then he gets mad at me for saying he
watched my stories but i have all of
those i check them like once every six
months
yeah that might be true i feel like
there's a chemistry here with you guys
you keep saying how much you know him
sounds kind of hot no it really is not
really shooting for a throuple right
here
thanks for the help have you ever had a
throuple
no you mean a threesome
no
no
okay he's not lying
i guess he could be a hoe it's just like
i uh i guess he could be sort of like
the rasputin type i just
i does that mean
like i don't know i uh i'm not that good
at judging men but it just seems like
he's got a lot of hair
he does have a lot of hair i'm donating
my hair so that's
that's nice i told him he looked like a
skinny maui the other day and he got mad
at me
yeah
um so uh if you guys had the date
what would it look like how would you
sneak it under uh
what's her name how would you cheat on
your girlfriend whereas how would you
cheat on you
how would you cheat on steph
i wouldn't
good answer wow
what a hoe
correct answer
this is so weird i don't know what to
say you guys are dating you
i don't know you you like i don't know i
don't understand why you say i know so
much about him and then you don't want
it because i've known him i've known him
for like 10 years though as a friend
like it sounds like a healthy and secure
dynamic i'm not saying
do you think men and women can be
friends or no
i don't think they should be i think
they should
[ __ ] i think that'd make a great porno
if you guys ever decide to
no i mean uh it's possible i just have
never seen it in the wild before
it's all theoretical
my hair the bear
yeah i mean that's so awesome you guys
are such good friends
uh so what's like the what kind of
activities have you guys done together
like friendly activities we travel a lot
to hawaii who's all going to hawaii
it's like eight of us damn three of the
eight are right here
this is what you get you want to go too
soon we've gone camping
yeah why not
if anybody would like to go to hawaii
with us it's an open invitation yeah i
want you well going to hawaii as a as a
crowd
i like this
you can come you can bring your
boyfriend
he can hire us all and then start
[ __ ] us
[Laughter]
i've always wanted to sue an employer
yeah we
yeah we need the paralegal to sue your
boyfriend nice sitcom going we can be a
quintuple
yeah
it's gonna be an origin yeah she's she's
my girlfriend when i don't have a
girlfriend so nice i'm a scientist yeah
i hate that
she she actually gets the benefit so i'm
taking her to the floor seats of bad
bunny because i broke up with an old
girlfriend
so
she gets like a 1500 ticket
bad bunny is that the catch me outside
girl
it's a bad baby
bad baby
you don't know who bad boy i'm 32 years
old that's okay dude i'm 28 and lee's
almost 28 too but bad bunny's bad bunny
you know who bad bunny is yeah i'm latin
hispanic
yeah so he i am getting the the better
end of this so he broke up with his
girlfriend who his idiot self bought
2500
dollar tickets
for like floor seats to go see him and
they broke up so i was like
yo yeah i kind of want to go too
so now we're getting the ticket but you
want to get astroworlded
i i was also at astroworld actually oh
astroworld survivor i was yeah i don't
mean to trigger you but uh it's all good
i went to therapy already we're good
hopefully travis got paid for it
why did you all break up you and your ex
it's not a thing we should talk about
right now
have you talked about it with your
girlfriend currently steph have you have
you discussed this yeah she knows
sick
cancun trip that
you're just taking him everywhere that's
insane i love that tell him he's a sugar
daddy who's not with her oh
boys trip
oh
okay okay i get it
okay
oil and gas you work in oil and gas no
actually i'm a consultant so i keep them
from doing the bad stuff oh you consult
uh you're like hey you should i consult
you to not do this
they're allowed to pollute i keep them
within their pollution limits which is
still very high control the damage it's
not that good but yeah
well you better because otherwise your
girlfriend's gonna sue you
yeah you don't do your job correctly i
could probably go to jail if i mess a
test up so
nice it's pretty bad hey
you gotta get in all those hawaiian
cancun trips before you go to prison
i will that's awesome
it's good to see uh you making it you
know you're 28 years old [ __ ] the
system or you know
doing doing your thing
so uh
have you ever like asked her out on a
date have you ever asked anna out on a
date
no we haven't oh so i actually the
reason i have a lot of girlfriends is
they have a lot of hot friends
that usually works out
if you were to take anna on a date
what do you think her favorite date
would be
you better not get this wrong i swear to
god
yeah if you were to take her on a date
what do you think like her favorite
ideal date would be
pretending
like
a george strait concert or a
bad any kind of concert or trip okay you
could have easily said soccer but
cool
yeah that that's a close shot
that was the pre-game would be a concert
post game would be a soccer game all
right okay
well you really are from austin
um i mean soccer i guess is popular now
well i'm from south texas and i'm
mexican so 956. yes nice yeah
that's cool so you're uh you're kind of
like badass you're like cut people thank
you yes
you should on the daily
at least you don't shoot them with the
ruger elise you and elise should meet
yeah where is she don't bring a gun
don't bring a knife to a gunfight
she left
uh so you guys have any crazy talents or
any skills you guys want to do an improv
exercise or sing a song together
not really now
what was the song we sang in in uh in
nashville
let's put some taylor swift karaoke on
oh
let's see how zach goes crazy yeah can
we get a little 22s we're two monitors
maybe uh google 22 taylor swift karaoke
and see uh zach m and anna really hit it
off
on a duet of friendship
a platonic duet
streaming
hispanics
el presidente zach m
and
his uh
his i don't know what what do you call a
female
his mujere anna
you just gotta feel it bro
just say whatever
taylor swift
feeling 22.
is there anything you want to say to
honor right now
while this music is playing
[Music]
no
zach you got to say something
you don't know about me
but i bet you i don't know did you go
zach just use this as a chance
you keep me next to you
you don't know about me
yeah
you really belt it out
as loud as you can
[Music]
step in the eye while you sing this
she's she's not paying attention to me
she does not like my karaoke
thank you he's sort of saying that that
we have four minorities on stage and
that was the whitest i felt all night oh
man
you can sing some bad bunny i know the
lyrics to those
bad bunnies he doesn't though i actually
don't speak spanish
2 000 spanish concert you were the
president of the hispanic association
exactly you don't speak spanish tell me
about it you're trying to keep being
hispanic right now
i just feel like maybe the president
should you know speak the way presidente
yeah
well that's great i mean there's more to
hispanic
uh pride than speaking spanish
i was trying to indoctrinate them into
you're in charge of the salsa you're
trying to colonialize it
you're working from the inside
give it up for zach m and anna
thank you guys so much for coming up
here
uh that was the show thank you guys so
much for coming give it up for
yourselves for coming out tonight
we do this every sunday at six there's
an open mic after this uh please stick
around uh what are your thoughts of the
all the dates tonight giuseppe i've had
so much fun yeah this is a blast this
was a blast yeah what did you think
about the uh
the detroit girl with a gun i love her
she speaks to me on a different level
but i don't think pink and purple do go
together yeah please don't hurt
especially on a gun
when it's pointed at you it's really
scary
i like being scared by women
yeah so did the so did elise's day
anthony w
i could see his boner from here beat his
match
um that was the show uh follow giuseppa
on uh instagram good luck spelling her
name if you if you can spell it you
deserve to follow her i will follow you
back if you can spell my name correct
she will follow you back
i'm dj hans kim uh other people comedy
on instagram thank you guys so much for
coming out have a good night thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
now
[Music]
you